all right so today I have I'm very happy
to have an interview with Vicente from
from Malaga in southern Spain where I've
been it's a wonderful part of the world
a wonderful part of Spain and Vicente is
one of this developing breed of
entrepreneurs of teachers who are
sharing their language with people
around the world so I want an interview
we think they about how he teaches
Spanish why people learn Spanish and so
forth but maybe I can begin vicente by
asking you to introduce yourself
well hola me llamo Vicente and I'm a
Spanish teacher on YouTube and I love
teaching Spanish and I started teaching
Spanish like three years ago not too
much but I really love what I do I love
teaching I love how people learn my
language and I think is one of the best
ways to spread my culture around the
world and yeah that's what I do I teach
a Spanish I love it and I do it every
day basically Wow every day we will
leave a link to within this channel you
know it's very interesting right now of
course people are stuck indoors I mean
that's the case in Spain it's the case
in Canada so it's it's an opportunity to
do things that we never had time to do
and I think it's very timely that that
all of these sort of language tutors or
language systems like link that are now
you know increasingly becoming sort of
mainstream that they're available to
people but what when you first started
three years ago what were sort of your
motivations what were your fears how did
you manage to get sort of this this
momentum behind behind your channel to
go for the for a YouTube channel and
online education we could say yeah yes
well um I was I was living in Manchester
when everything is started and one day I
was working at restaurant and one day I
did my first lesson teaching a Spanish
um foreign languages teacher I didn't
say that and and that moment when I did
the first lesson I spent almost four
hours preparing the lesson
for only one hour lesson and when when
the lesson started is just finishing
like five minutes for me
and it was one hour and I felt like I
really loved it so from that moment I I
told myself this is what I want to do
the rest of my we could say the rest of
my life because I liked it and the time
flies when I do this so that moment I
decide to do that but the thing is that
I'm from Malaga and I missed my city so
I wanted to come back so teaching online
was we could say the bridge to let me
come here and give me this kind of
freedom so that was the moment I decided
to teach teach online and when I did the
first video on on YouTube I could see
how language could could reach different
corners in the world different countries
so it's something that I feel in it's
like I feel like inside how people can
learn from something I do in a room and
that was that was probably the first
motivation I had to start all the online
teaching and and so on I would say yeah
wonderful and Malaga you know Spanish
the one thing about Spanish is that you
have so many different cultures actually
that speak Spanish so you know you go to
Malaga you're in under lufia you're in
an area that was influenced by Arabic
culture and you see evidence of that in
the area but you can go to Mexico you
can I was in Peru I was in Argentina you
know all these countries have very much
their own culture as well as sharing the
broader Spanish culture what advice do
you give and I often get this question
when people are interested in Spanish
which Spanish should I learn should I
learn Mexican Spanish should I learn
Colombian Spanish Spanish Spanish what
do you say to them well I would say it
depends what you want to use it for
where do you want to leave or what what
do you want to do because I cannot tell
you oh you have to learn Spanish from
Spain Castilian Castilla known as
say no it's not there is not like a
perfect Spanish if you if you for
example if you are going to marry with a
Mexican person of course we're going to
need this kind as Mexican Spanish we
would say and I think it depends what
you want a Spanish for where you're
going to leave there is not the I would
say is not the perfect Spanish but but
wouldn't you say I mean my impression of
Spanish mm-hmm is that the differences
are not that great
there is slang there is you know
whatever Venezuelan slang or Cuban slang
or so forth but overwhelming it's just
overwhelmingly it's the same words and
so my advice to people especially when
they're beginners you can't even hear
the difference you you have to learn the
basic working words of the language at
some later point if you're gonna be
living in a particular spanish-speaking
country you can focus in on that
particular accent but I think for the
longest time
people should listen to and read content
from everywhere what do you think of
that that's been my advice all the time
yeah definitely I would say also that
that you have sometimes you have to
watch content in different I don't know
how to say variants variants of Spanish
variants variants of Spanish in fact
when I teach my students they are living
in Spain some of them and I also I also
used like Mexican videos or Peruvian
believe in videos from Chile videos to
teach them Spanish because I also want
them to see how different it to be the
pronunciation and everything but of
course we cannot we cannot limit ourself
to something because if you do that at
the moment of the student getting
contact with a different variant of
Spanish they will feel like oh this is
something completely different for me
and I think we and they have we have to
be flexible when we teach them our
language is Spanish yeah yeah I agree
with you I mean we're saying 500 million
speakers there's not five hundred
million people in Spain yeah
so and and
Bain has regional variations too and has
cultural differences from region to
region and and that's part of the
attraction of Spanish it connects you
with so many different types of music
different types of food now let me ask
you another question what are the major
when you're learners and I I'm guessing
but a lot of them are English speakers
but I presume you have all kinds of
different you know national groups what
are the biggest difficulties that people
find with Spanish with a Spanish
language mm-hmm well depends sometimes
from what is students native language
for example for English speakers one of
the main difficulties is past tenses
past tenses ser and estar which is
because in English is only 2 B but in
Spain in Spanish we have ser and estar
and I I understand that that is really
confusing but for example for another
kind of students for example students
who come from Russia and they speak
Russian one of the main difficulties it
could be the articles but also the cell
understand so I would say some of the
grammar aspects are difficult for them
but I feel that they don't have to focus
too much on the grammar things and as we
say in our interview them you have to be
more like care less about the mistakes
because as you say before mistakes will
make you do less mistakes yeah I should
say we had an interview in Spanish oh
yeah Aventis channel and we'll put a
link up here in the description box but
yeah I mean you say the Russians have
difficulty with articles they have
difficulty with articles in English too
but I say it serves them right because I
have similar difficulties in Russian you
know there are things that if they don't
exist in your own language you are gonna
have difficulty in another language for
sure and you just have to have so much
input that gradually these become you
know habits and it can take a long time
and you may never get there I have
people that I work with in Russian that
speak English very well express
themselves very well and
there are articles like 50% and they're
never gonna get better than 50% and it
really doesn't matter and I suspect that
in Spanish if you speak Spanish well and
you use large you know vocabulary and
you make mistakes with ser and estar
here and there it doesn't upset the
average Spanish speaker yeah is that
correct like how does the average native
speaker of Spanish react when he hears
ser instead of a star
so I Philippe instead of estoy Feliz
does that cause a problem no never
because because it doesn't like it
doesn't interrupt the communication no
one is going to stop you and say oh wait
wait what what do you say oh you say so
if Oliva Stephanie they are going to
keep the conversation okay probably if
it's someone that knows you later or
probably they could correct you but
probably not someone on the street they
are not going to correct you and they
are not going to interrupt the
conversation because you made a small
mistake that's not gonna happen I think
and I must say you know when I've taught
English you know to our members at link
correcting people doesn't necessarily
mean they're gonna get it right the next
time
and similarly when I have my lessons in
Persian or whatever Arabic and I find
this I review my notes because my tutor
will always create like a list of ten or
fifteen mistakes phrases that I didn't
use correctly and they send them to me
and I keep these as a course so that I
can review them like three months ago
and what I find is I make the mistake
the same mistake every week like she
keeps not correcting me and I make the
same mistake week after week after week
and maybe at some point I stopped making
that mistake so I mean that's just part
of the process we just have to make
mistakes in order to eventually make
fewer mistakes I agree I agree with her
sorry I agree with that because I'm I'm
learning Russian now and with my teacher
and I always say adenine adenine segundo
pasados da and my teacher my teacher
told me at new at noon seven secondo and
he's like that every every single lesson
and the other day I just wrote a whole
paper with at noon Segundo and I would
never forget that I will never forget
that mistake you
you hope you'll never forget yeah you
might again definitely definitely how
how do you think that the online class
is different from the traditional
classroom well this is some of the
methods your instruction the way you
teach how is it different from because
you say you are a language teacher a
trained language teacher so what do you
do differently when you're teaching
online as opposed to when you were in a
classroom well most of the people think
that when I'm talking when I started I
started 3 3 month 3 years ago
sorry this online thing it wasn't to
usual 3 years ago but now there is as
you say before people we have to learn
online nowadays with everything that is
going on in the world and I think for me
online lessons online learning is more
flexible because you have everything you
need in your keyboard you just need to
type it on a searcher like Google or
Yahoo and you find it so I would say
that online lessons they are more
flexible and there is not any kind of
limitation if you want to have six
students you can have a video call with
six students if you want to do a live
exam you can do it with the tools like a
hood for example and if you want to
share a video you have an app or a tool
like YouTube or watch together or
anything you have it here you don't need
to go somewhere so for me I would say
that online teaching is like it allows
you to use whatever is around us and I
would say that is the main advantage if
you compare with like percentual lessons
you know it's it's funny the online
teaching is something that has grown
quite rapidly over the years but we're
now in a situation where it's a
necessity yes and you wonder how the
world is gonna change once we get to the
other end of this this coronavirus
pandemic you know for example medicine I
now here we we are not we are told not
to go to the doctor's office we use we
have to contact the doctor remotely and
and the doctor can prescribe or you know
and and but that's a better way of doing
things actually and I'm just wondering
if if you know when I look at people who
fly to Vancouver from Mexico or Korea or
wherever and study in schools here and
the cost of doing that I wonder if there
won't be a shift towards more online
teaching and and conversely if the
online teaching sort of methodology
won't evolve so that we'll end up with a
different paradigm because right now
most people learn in a traditional
classroom as much as the online teaching
has has grown it's still a very small
part of the total you know language
learning market call it do you think
that's gonna change yes definitely as
you say that with all this carniverous
thing under on the pandemic online
teaching before it was a kind of
complement for the lessons but I think
that from now unknown online teaching is
going to be like the core the main part
and do you say presidential lessons like
a physical lesson I don't know how to
say in English physical art is called
traditional class traditional classrooms
now online teaching is going to be like
the main the most important part and the
traditional classrooms are going to be
like a compliment
so I've seen that is going to be the
main change for the online education I
would say definitely okay well maybe
we'll leave it there we had we won't
speak Spanish today because we spoke
Spanish in our previous interview which
you can all go and watch on Vicente
Channel but I'm just gonna close up I'm
gonna ask you to say some final words
but I just want to say that Spanish is a
wonderful language to learn it opens up
not only Spanish but all of the romance
languages so it's not just 500 million
people it's 750 million people it's a
big part of history the Mediterranean
Latin America and so forth it's not that
difficult to learn it's a more and more
important language every day in the
United States so go for Spanish and go
and visit the dentist Channel and maybe
you could end up with some words of
encouragement to people who who are
interested in Spanish which is thank you
thank you as if it was
okay all right then so thank you we hit
a mooch I got has a DS okay thank you to
you guys
yes yes yes bye
[Music]